الحرب العالميه الاولى جعلت القانون
الامريكي موجودا والان حرب اخرى في
اوكرانيا تستنزف ميزانيه واشنطن وجعلت جمع
الضرائب اقل من المتوقع لتكون واشنطن امام
حلين احلاهما مروا الاول التخلف عن السداد
وهنا كارثه معنى ذلك ان واشنطن لم تعد
قادره على رفع فوائد ديونها ستضطر للدخول
في مفاوضات مع الدائنين الذين بدورهم
سيضطرون للجدوله ديونهم او شتوي جزء منها
ارتفاع الديون يعني ان هناك الكثير ممن هم
مستعدون لاقراض واشنطن لماذا لان الديون
الامريكيه تعتبر استثمارا مضمونا بمخاطر
شبه معدومه لكن عجز امريكا عن السداد
سيجعل الثقه في سنداتها تهتز والفائده تر
تفع ما يجعل المستثمرين يفرون من اسواق
امريكا بسبب غلاء القروض فداعيات ستصل لنا
جميعا
[موسيقى]
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات